I mean I find myself
slightly bewildered and disoriented by
having to make the case for free speech
yeah something that I I would have
thought would have been so basic or even
sort of cringe to have to speak out
about Free Speech because it just seems
so obvious I mean who would need to
defend Free Speech but here we are in a
situation where we have to tell young
people in particular that they are they
should not be protected from things that
they find offensive that being offended
is part of being alive
uh having negative emotions having
negative reactions feeling angry feeling
upset this is part of what it means to
be fully human and the idea that adults
or somebody should protect you from that
it's absolutely absurd